listen i'm gonna be late they put me on  another flight  i love you baby  there's been an incident a 950's  disappeared over the atlantic  i'm sorry howard i need you you're the  only one who can find this plane  is this strange that there was no mayday  of any kind it could have been hijacking  somebody on board wanted that aircraft  to disappear  they found debris no a survivor  was our miracle survivor prime suspect  this is an interrogation what are you  accusing me of it wasn't an accident  terrorist causes crash could look like  an act of war the van's following us  people went to great lengths to cover up  what crash flight 716.  i go where the evidence takes me  we need to hear what happened on that  flight we need the truth  [Music]  you